I guess the most controversial stand
which libertarians have now is on drugs
you probably get a lot of criticism
because you want to legalize drugs right
well but I think the most controversy I
think about the whole drug problem is is
zero tolerance that's that's what's
controversial this idea that we have no
privacy there's no financial privacy or
privacy in our home because the Drug
Enforcement Agency can break our doors
down looking for a cigarette butt they
confiscate cars and boats and houses are
bulldozed in all in the name of teaching
people not to have bad habits they're
spending ten billion dollars I think
it's an incredible program of failure so
the controversy is really in the hands
of the government Democrats and
Republicans who are saying the same
thing in each party tries to outdo the
other and they're actually absolutely
obsessed with this at the same time they
care not unlit about you know our civil
liberties but the drug laws I've only
been here since nineteen fourteen about
that time we had the income tax the
Federal Reserve System the FBI a
licensing to protect certain industries
and professions then we decided we're
going to tell people how to live and
what their habits ought to be that's
when they introduced the ideas of
prohibition of alcohol didn't work very
well and so that was finally repealed
libertarians detest drug dealers that's
one reason why we want to get rid of the
laws we want to get the drug dealer out
of business overnight because he can't
exist unless the drug price is very high
so a lot of good people inadvertent Lane
are the allies of the drug dealers if
they like the drug laws the people who
write those laws in life those laws
inadvertently promote crime every drug
addict because he has to pay these
exorbitant remotes for their drugs
commit on the average two hundred and
sixty that one he's a year to raise the
money that would be totally on this a
who raises that kind of money to go buy
a six pack at the drugstore I don't have
to do that because he alcohols available
now the hawk kills more people than
drugs cigarettes they kill 300
5,000 people a year and what a way
required to subsidize tobacco industry
if people want to really do good that's
just quick to subsidizing tobacco get
the government out of the sale of
alcohol and and go that way but the
crime rate would go down the drug
dealers would be out of business I think
the kids wouldn't be as exposed either
it's pretty hard to tell a kid that's
just dropped out of a public school
where he was totally bored and he's on
the street corner he decides he wants a
job and buy a car talk him into working
at McDonald's no no but he can make $400
a day doing a little work for the local
drug merchants there's no way he's
tempted and he yields to the temptation
so we literally set the stage by these
drug laws to get more kids involved and
I think that's horrible I think the kids
have to they certainly deserve some
protection we deserve at least to create
an environment where they're not so
likely to be forced into the drug trade
now you're a medical doctor and you
think that legalizing all these drugs
would be good does the do your medical
colleagues and the medical profession
they agree with this no to a minority
matter of fact I think that even drugs
for treating oneself should be more
readily available to people not I think
people should do it unwisely and use a
lot of fancy medication without some
advice but if drugs were more available
you know if a nurse could prescribe
penicillin it certainly would be a lot
cheaper nurses are capable of telling
you whether you have a strep throat or
not we drive the cost down so doctors
have a little protectionism involved
they like their little monopolies so the
AMA kind of like the AMA lobbied me in
Washington to vote against even allowing
doctors to give heroin for dying cancer
patients who couldn't have their pain
relief from morphine but they were they
they did not want this to happen because
it didn't want they wanted to have
control they didn't look like they were
soft on drugs but they won control so
whether it's the drugs necessary right
now the FDA I think is as a horrible
disservice to us all by making it very
difficult for aids and cancer patients
to do alternative treatments you know
they're smuggling drugs from Mexico you
know we think of Mexico as a socialist
state and yet they
can get drugs more readily there and
we're having dying cancer patient a
patient smuggling drugs up into the free
United States in order for them to take
this medicine but FDA argues well we got
to make sure it's safe and effective
well if somebody's dying don't you think
they have the right to take a chance on
that drug and an experimental drug but
the AMA isn't helpful in here in the
medical profession is very poor a lot of
doctors would agree with me but I think
they like the idea that they're sort of
godlike and they get to write
prescriptions and they certainly think
that opening up this whole bearer also
to speak would be detrimental to their
protection in there and they're
interested in organized medicine what
about the police
and law enforcement profession would
they be for your point of view it would
put a lot of them out of work I think a
lot of would make a lot less money you
know it's their system has been
corrupted by oh gosh it's a you know
another example of how fully some of
these laws are is they the prisons are
running rampant with drugs if we can't
keep drugs out of the prison how are we
going to keep drugs off the street which
means it's very very much a corrupting
influence I mean we we read stories I'm
sure the majority of the police are not
involved but you don't need very many to
really make a lot of money off it so
there are gonna be some officials who
would agree with us and I've had some I
haven't there was an interesting story
of an individual and my staff went to
work for a candidate who was running for
governor ship in a large city and they
brought all the district attorneys
together because crime was the number
one issue in that state and they made
them there they said that the only way
you could ever get rid of crime would be
and they all agreed on this is you'd
have to give it to the drug law so
behind closed door without the press
they agreed the drug laws created a
crime and you know what they said you
can't ever achieve that because there
are too many people on the take too many
judgment too many ways like this so just
forget about it we can't deal with it
it's too much of an emotional issue
anyway but it is an important issue I
think the discussion has progressed a
whole lot in the last six months I think
we as libertarians have done a
a lot of good in getting this discussion
out and I am going to continue to debate
this because as a parent of five
children and as a physician and as a non
drug user I think that I have some
credibility and in making this debate on
the idea that drugs ought to be
decriminalized